[Music]
all right we're gonna play
e5
let's play e5
okay so we're facing a scotch we're
facing a scotch
and if he takes on d4 it'll be a scotch
gambit otherwise it'll be
a uh italian scotch
or sorry a regular scotch that we have
to take
scotch in spain that almost doesn't make
any sense yeah so now white has this big
choice between bishop c4 that's the
scotch gamut and then knight takes d4 is
the traditional scotch
okay knight takes d4 if you're any five
player there's like a million ways to
face the scotch the two main moves are
bishop c5 and knight f6 my
main move is bishop c5 and has been for
the past few years
and here
those of you who are
theory experts
should know that black has this move
queen f6 or if you've seen charlie
against xqc
i actually feel like taking straight
away
is perfectly good enough and not enough
people do it and then there's a very
interesting system
that i'm going to play if he plays
knight c3 which is the main move but a
lot of people don't even realize that
black can simply take back on c6
okay so we're already playing in 2000
bishop c4 bishop c4 so he develops the
bishop
that's kind of an interesting move
now there are
different ways the black can position
their pieces
obviously one of them is you can just
play d6
you can put your queen on f6 and then
play knight e7
there there are like several options on
the menu
there's also queen h4 you can play queen
h4
and then if white castles you can
quickly get the knight out to f6 and try
to get to g4
so let's see what happens if we play
super aggressively let's throw in queen
h4
but the point is that
after white castles we shouldn't
take the pawn on e4
because if we take that pawn we get
pinned rookie one
so the point of queen h4 isn't to
win the pawn on e4 although if white
doesn't castle we will
the point is to quickly get the knight
to f6 and then to threaten knight g4
and you should be familiar with this
construction queen on h4 knight on g4
bishop on this diagonal
and our opponent
is probably familiar with this but one
second
so wait what happens if we play knight
g4
we play knight g4 y plays knight f3
we play knight takes f2 wow there's
actually some crazy tactics there
let me think
knight g4 knight f3 knight takes f2
so we're attacking white's queen white's
attacking our queen
no clue what's going on there
but we can also just castle we don't
have to play night g4 we can also just
castle so after the game i'll explain
some of the
the complications to y'all
but let's just castle because
now we're threatening knight chief ori
in earnest and if white plays knight f3
we can already take the pawn on e4 so
this is actually a very tricky move yeah
so so our opponent gives us the center
pawn i don't know if he has something in
mind i think this is just a blunder
and now we have an extra pawn and now
our our last remaining priority for the
opening is to get this bishop out of the
gates the bishop on c8 is currently
hemmed in by our pawns
so we want to play either d6 or d5
depending on what white does
get this bishop out and we'll just be a
healthy pawn up
okay b3
so the the only thing that that concerns
me here is the placement of our queen
i don't want our queen to hang out on e4
for too long and i'm pretty sure that
white is going to attack our queen and
we're going to be forced out of the way
so we should play d5 here
and the reason that i'm not playing d6
is because
if you look at the e4 square
currently it's occupied by the queen but
after bishop d3 have okay rookie one
what's going to happen is that we're
going to get that square available and
we might be able to put our knight there
after the queen moves
where should the queen go
there are several options here
we can go
one interesting thing we can do is we
can go back to g6 we can also go a
little bit more aggressively queen g4
i like queen g4 because it's very active
and if white plays h3 we can drop the
queen back to h5 i like queen g4 a lot
okay h3
so let me think for a second ah we
actually have
several
very interesting options
we need to be very careful because if we
go
queen h5 there's this move rookie five
queen g6 is susceptible to
all sorts of moves
like 95 but 95 we have queen f5
so queen g6 bishop d3
then there's 94 there's also queen g3
some of you are noticing
but if we play queen g3 white we'll play
bishop e3
and then we take it white takes with a
rook we have to move our queen again and
we can move it back to d6 so queen g3 is
fine
i'm trying to find something better so
give me a second to think which is
something you occasionally have to do
so i actually like
i actually like queen g6 and i'll
explain this a little bit more after the
game but there's a very concrete line
that i'm calculating
what i like about this move
is that it also threatens
bishop takes h3 which as you can
understand is a pretty devastating
threat
now you might say but i don't get it i
can play bishop d3 and we can't take on
h3 because our queen is hanging well
bishop d3 can be met with knight e4
that's why we played d5 we played d5 to
be able to stick a knight on e4
and you might say but can't white take
the knight but then we take back we're
attacking white's knight and we're still
threatening bishop takes h3 and
on top of that we're threatening the f2
pawn so despite the knight being pinned
it's still attacking the f2 pawn
something a lot of people don't
understand a pinned piece isn't
necessarily fully immobilized it can
also do something
now i think if okay bishop takes e4 i
think is a mistake
so we of course
have to take and i think our opponent is
relying on knight h4 having missed our
response to that move no 95
but now we have many options
and i think the
the prettiest one is queen g3 is that
the best one
yeah it probably
also is the best one we can also play
queen f6
queen f6 is also good but i think this
is very pretty
and i don't see a reason not to play
this movie it doesn't win if white plays
accurately i think white is still okay
okay okay is relatively speaking okay
white is not losing on the spot
but i think in the end we're probably
gonna go go two pawns up and liquidate
into an end game if i if i'm
anticipating this correctly
we're eventually gonna get an end game
where we're two pawns up yet so here we
should start by taking f2
there's a ton of tactics that i'll
explain after the game so for example
some of you might say well can't we play
bishop takes h3 here but white has this
move queen f3
a lot of you might be tempted to take on
f2 with the queen but there's a specific
reason that i want to take on f2 with
the bishop and the reason
is that after king h1 i think we have an
additional tactical resource that wins
another pawn so okay king f1 so that's a
moot point
i wasn't expecting king f1
so what should we do now
we should probably
we should probably move the bishop away
from f2 in order to threaten queen f2
checkmate a lot of you want to play
bishop a6 check but then white plays c4
so i'm not exactly sure what that gives
us
other than a bad bishop i want to keep
this bishop on c8 so that we can sack on
h3
if if an opportunity arises but stacking
on h3 immediately as i know a lot of you
want to play i think is a bad idea
because white's just going to take that
bishop
and we're going to give a scary looking
check on g1 white plays can you too and
i don't think there's a follow-up there
so i actually like the idea
of just moving the bishop back to b6
and creating
a massive thread of queen f2 obviously
that's mate
white should defend that probably with
queen f3 and their okay that is crazy
once it comes to the pressure
i guess our opponent just lost his
patience
well 2 000 misses me
that's pretty crazy despite the ending
this was pretty instructive i think
attacking chess even if i didn't play
too accurately
in this position
the other main move is knight f6 the
reason i don't like it as much as bishop
c5 is because
the main line here is knight takes c6
bc
and then this move e5 i don't know how
many of you have seen this before
and then black plays this very weird
looking move queen e7 pinning the pawn
queen e2
and then knight d5
i wouldn't necessarily say that white
played that badly it was just a bad game
yeah and after c4 there's bishop a6
there's a very uh well-studied
theoretical line here gary kasparov has
played this a bunch with white so this
is just something that you should know
if you want to play that f6
in my opinion bishop c5 is a little bit
easier to learn
and a little bit more structurally
sounding
but after knight 66 all of the books
recommend queen
f6 this threatens checkmate
and if i remember correctly the main
move here is queen
d2
now you can play both bc and dc
but the main move is dc
and then you get a position like this
which is very interesting i mean this is
supposed to be equal
but a less studied move is b takes c6
this is a lot more rare than queen f6
bishop c4 is a move but i don't think
it's great so in these types of
positions if you're playing white
it's important to realize that the
bishop actually belongs on d3 most of
the time
because precisely because of what
happened in the game like the pawn on e4
is both an asset but also a weakness in
many positions
so it's important to defend it
preemptively
and if we do the same thing that we did
in the game if we play queen h4 white
can further defend the pawn with queenie
two
so there are 23 games here that i see
knight f6
then people actually play h3
and then g3
oh and the queen is sort of trapped so
you have to go here
so this just leads to a very complicated
position potentially an endgame
isn't the double bond bad well i've
talked about that many times it's it's
not great but it's not the only factor
in the position
and there are other factors in the
position which are in box favors such as
the fact that when we played d5
the c pawns could actually be good like
the c6 pawn supports the d5 square
so in and of itself the double bonds
don't really tell you much about the
position
yeah it's a factor that works in white's
advantage but there's a million other
things to point out in this position
such as the fact that black has a
development advantage right we've
developed a piece and why it hasn't
and that hurt white in this position do
you ever play a5 in these well yeah you
do play a5 sometimes so the move a5 and
such positions can act
can serve primarily two reasons the
first is that it can just grab space on
the queen side
which can be good in certain positions
but the main thing a5 often does is it
creates the potential of bishop a6
so you can imagine a situation where the
bishop is gone
and the queen sits on this diagonal you
often see people going a5 and bishop a6
uh to activate the bishop you also see
this sometimes in the french
from the white side
it's always a good idea to
understand when ideas exist in various
openings and in the win hour of french
there is a very typical idea
very very typical idea
of playing a4 and bishop a3 to put the
bishop on an optimal square
even after 97
which is
uh which is the main line one of the
main sidelines is a4
this is like a move that's existed
forever
yeah to answer your question a5 is
definitely a viable idea but not
not anytime soon
okay so we decided on playing very
aggressively we play queen h4
now not queen takes c4 rookie one that's
a classic fin
but the point of putting the queen on h4
is that the queen pressures after an h2
at the same time
and knight f6 creates this massive
threat of knight you four if you're new
to chess you should remember
this pattern there are three ingredients
to this pattern you have the classic
queen and knight combo
which is scary in and of itself
but the addition of the bishop means
that f2 is also going to be hanging if
you put the knight on g4 so then the
question arises well why didn't i do
that right why did why didn't we play
knight g4 this looks really really good
the reason i didn't play it is because
of this move knight d2 to f3
and thank you copeland you might say
well wait a minute i could just play
bishop takes f2 check but you can't stop
calculating here you've only won a pawn
and notice that you haven't castled you
haven't developed your bishop and you've
also opened up the f file which could
work in white's favor because of the
pressure on the f7 pawn
so white moves the king aside the king
is actually very safe on h1
h2 is defended by the knight so you
cannot take on h2
you have to move your queen it's hanging
let's say you move it back to h5 and i
was not convinced i was not convinced
that this position is good for black
at all
just because all of our pieces seem to
be suspended in mid-air but maybe it is
maybe this is fine for black i don't
actually see a specific move for white
uh but maybe something like queen to e2
i don't know
queen to e2
i guess we just moved the bishop back
then
but this half open f file is what
worried me
i just didn't see the point
um
so instead we decided to very patiently
castle
solving the problems of the file now now
there's nothing to be afraid of because
the rook defense f7
and our opponent gave up upon like
things started going downhill for right
here i already think that white is worse
because the bishop is very misplaced
and this is a good illustration of why
in such positions the bishop belongs on
d3 if the bishop is on d3 here white
would play knight f3 with zero problems
with the bishop being on c4 it blunders
the pawn and attacks the bishop
simultaneously so
i don't really know what white should do
here
maybe queen e2
but then we can already strike with d5
and the bishop comes out to g4
this is a big initiative for black it
also hurts white that the bishop on c1
is blocked by the knight and as we
already established moving the knight
away gives up the pawn so
this is a tough position for white no
question about it
in any case
castles
knight f3
queen takes c4
yeah so bishop c4 i think was a very
serious inaccuracy in the opening
actually
so we take the pawn
we go d5 which is a very reasonable move
and now
here
the alternative to queen g4 is to drop
it back to g6 but i feel like queen g4
is just a more active and aggressive
move
also queen g6
thank you barasa prasadan allows this
weird move knight h4
very very strange move but it actually
forces a queen trade you know the funny
thing is this exact idea
occurs in a very similar position in the
jubal one and the reason i know about
this
is because in the jubal london which i
play very often
there is this idea
and let me give you an example of where
it arises so
yeah so basically something like
yeah okay so something like this where
you suddenly play queen at knight a4
and the queen has to move to a5 and that
forces a queen [ __ ] in some cases that
actually traps the queen
so we played d5
then we played back to g6
and you might ask why didn't we play
queen g3 here
because white can't take the reason is
this move bishop e3
and when you are relying on a pin to
save the queen you have to be very very
careful because if the pinned piece is
distracted the queen is automatically
hanging
so you're going to end up losing a bunch
of tempe after bishop e3 you can't just
take on c4 your queen is now hanging
and after you take okay white can't take
the queen at this point but he can't
take the bishop back and again the queen
is hanging
and we can drop the queen back to d6 and
we're up a pawn and black is better but
i didn't want to give away my dark
squared bishop that easily and that's
why we played queen g6
if white plays knight h4 now
what was my idea
so this is a very important subtlety
now the knight is undefended
how does that help us
now we play queen g3 exactly so just
because an idea doesn't work in one
position
doesn't mean that you reject it overall
now queen g3 works what's the difference
the difference is that it's a fork the
knight is now hanging bishop e3 you take
the bishop and now you have queen takes
h4 and europa peace
so that's actually a very nice trip
after 95
here again you don't want to go queen g3
because of bishop e3
and you might say wait a second then
isn't the knight hanging here too it is
but you can't capture it because if you
take it like white takes c5 and it's a
discovery and if you take the bishop
first then the rope takes and it defends
the knight so just concretely this
doesn't work what should black do here
where should we go with our queen
where should we go with our queen
yeah you should go to f5
and the point is that now you're
attacking f2 from two different
directions and you're attacking the
bishop and again it's a fork it's a
double attack so after bishop d3 we
stick the knight on e4
how do i know that this pin is not
dangerous mostly it's because there's a
pawn that is defending the knight and
i've talked about this many times on the
speed run
when you have a pawn that is defending a
pinned piece the pin automatically
becomes less dangerous
plus we're attacking the f2 pawn now
white should have certainly gone bishop
e3
i think bishop p3 was the last chance
for white to stay in the game but
here
we can
take on e3
and the funny thing is
we actually
cannot take on h3 as far as i can tell
this is a bad move
who can tell me why
where do beginners go for puzzles after
made in one just go to chess.com puzzles
and it'll automatically give you easy
problems to start and it'll adjust yeah
knight h4
very common trick attacking the bishop
attacking the queen
very easy to blunder this kind of thing
okay
black is still okay probably you can
play queen f6 and take this pawn
but why why give up the piece right
why give up the piece so so here i would
have probably gone f5 for example
to support the knight
and now we're threatening f4
position sucks for white you've got a
monster knight to bump upon and you've
got an attack against the king but still
this would have kept white in the game
after the trade there are way too many
threats
i mean white is just busted on all the
diagonals
and after 95 queen g3
unfortunately
rook takes e4 keeps white more or less
in the game i think king f1 is probably
the decisive mistake
what was the idea after king h1 well any
time the king is out of squares you look
for tactics and you should see the move
bishop takes h3
if takes the queen takes h3 is
mate white has this move queen f3 and
now we trade queens we drop our bishop
back and we're up two pawns and we're
winning and we're up two points in an
end game
yeah white does offer a trade by playing
queen f3 that's the point
oh
yeah why not bishop b3 after queen g3
because bishop b3 we can take the knight
simultaneously defending the bishop
don't forget that the knight is also
hanging here so this is a fork
[Music]
yeah so this is a great example of like
a lot of people would automatically play
this move thinking it's made but there
is c4
always when when there's a
large distance between a checking piece
and the king
you should look for ways to block the
check
and the bishop is now totally
ineffective because of this pawn chain
so we play bishop v6 it's a slow move
but it creates a huge threat
now of course white should have played
queen f3 but i think the black has a an
excellent attacking move here
so ideally you want to not trade queens
like if you trade queens it's fine
you're still up upon but if you can keep
the queens on the board the king is
totally busted so i really like the move
queen h2
what if knight d3 in the position where
each forked the f2 pawn in the knight
well knight t3 you just take it there's
a funny there's still the pawn on e4
so we have this move queen h2
and the queen is infiltrating to g1 the
rook is coming out
the bishop is coming out
okay white is obviously lost but perhaps
he could have prolonged the game for
another couple of moves also notice that
you can't move the bishop out because
this actually just wins the rook in the
corner
so
in any case
white blundered made so that ended the
game quickly but hopefully you guys
enjoy the game
and enjoy the stream i'm gonna get going
i have a lot to do
have a good one see you tomorrow bye
[Music]
you